Oh, look, look.
(upbeat music)
"In the Dark" is a new show
about a woman in her twenties
who's just a hot mess.
Hot mess.
A walking tornado.
She doesn't do anything
except eat candy bars and take naps.
Think blacking out
would be a little easier
when you're blind.
(man chuckles)
She is the witness to the murder of
a young boy named Tyson, who
happens to be her best friend,
and by trying to understand
why that happened
she's required to pick
her life up a little bit.
Today, we're going to answer
some adulting questions
from some puppies.
Puppies!
Hi.
Oooh!
(Upbeat music)
- No.
- Yes.
Oh!
(Brooke laughing)
I think if you love someone
and you feel it in your heart,
you should tell them.
Don't tell him.
It's too soon.
Baby, it's too soon.
- Oh boy.
- Oh my god.
Oh yeah, she's (mumbles).
Personally, I wouldn't text.
A text is so impersonal,
but a nice letter from
an unknown location,
you can't beat it.
[Keston] I'm sorry.
(Keston laughing)
[Morgan] It's the best way
I know how to break up.
It's snail mail.
Just move.
Start a new life, new identity,
and get a new license.
Hi.
Oh, I'm sorry. You're very loosey-goosey.
Hank, I think it's okay to be nervous
and to get a little sweaty.
I always get the upper-lip
sweat right here.
- I always just point it out.
- Yeah.
And then people are like,
"Oh, I get that too."
And then it's like, oh great.
Hi.
Hi, sweetheart.
Don't cry.
I don't know why this one got me.
I think you should get my name.
(Perry laughing)
If I saw a dog with a cat tattoo,
I'd be like...
Have you asked Logan
how he feels about that?
- No.
- He's escaping.
Logan!
He's, like, I don't want a cat tattoo.
This is the best day of my life.
(Perry laughing)
[Casey] Be sure to check out
"In the Dark" on CW,
on Thursday, April 4 at 9 p.m.
If you're looking to adopt a dog,
go to Deity Animal Rescue and Foundation.
Because that's where you were.
Ow. Just bit my beard.
Just bit my beard.
Hey, hey.
Hey, what is the problem?